les soldats du feu arrivés sur l'
incendie hier après-midi ont travaillé
sans relâche jusqu'à 7 heures du matin
35 pompiers relever aujourd'hui par une
vingtaine de collègues toujours pénalisé
par le manque d'eau le premier point
d'alimentation est à 900 m surprenant
pour un site industriel de douze mille
mètres carrés la cie les pompiers ont dû
presque vide et un réservoir de la smf
et ce matin pour attaquer le feu à
revers ils vont ouvrir un chemin avec un
engin pour installer une pompe dans une
rivière voisine
elle sera placée ici c'est le plateau on
prévoit de la maintenir si c'est qu'on
est les tractopelles pourront entrer sur
site
les foyers le feu il déjà en profondeur
donc il nous faut les flammes les foyers
il faut extraire les matériaux qui sont
déjà en surface pour pouvoir avec une
lance arrosez les huit salariés qui ont
vu leur outil de travail partir en fumée
savent qu'ils l'ont échappé belle
le feu est parti de la zone de
dépollution des véhicules une explosion
en tout cas et café une explosion et ça
ça change la mi temps d'arriver le
premier et 5 d'arrivée d'un luxe a
commencé à fumer encore davantage à
l'avantagé du bon c'est un taxi qui est
là dedans on veut nous acculer on
appelle les pompiers
et là ça en quelques minutes 15 secondes
tout s'est embrasé tout le site
alors quelle est l'origine de cette
explosion peut-être un déchets laissés
dans un village du type aérosol ou comme
déjà vu des munitions dans une boîte à
gants les vertus doivent être vidés
avant d'entrer sur ce site qui n'est pas
une casse mais une entreprise de
recyclage des métaux la seule demartini
un investissement de plus d'un million
d'euros
le patron resté sur place toute la nuit
souhaite plus que tout pouvoir sauver
son activité